my name is sergey listopad born and raised in Kyiv was an active participant in the maidan developing websites and currently a volunteer in the ato zone helping ukrainian military and civilians who suffered from the war which was the night of december 11 when i opened facebook and saw that the dispersal had begun it’s just that now thousands of policemen are beating protesters, breaking down barricades, and it’s not clear that I then made one of the most difficult decisions in my life, I got dressed and came here at night because but I couldn’t do otherwise and already here I met a bunch of my friends at someone's little children were really there for years two months friend my child of the year he left and his pregnant wife and he left and came I met here my friend the TV presenter who is a very public character and well he risked his career and reputation risked everything we were in the forefront there on the barricade on the last standing barricade and we stayed here until that moment until about
they opened the subway in the morning and
people from all over the city did not start to
come to the court, this would be psychologically the
most difficult